[Music]
it's good to see you playing well with
others again
just like a bad a diggin may be
temporary hey everybody you guys
requested new Nightwing Justice League
so this video is going to be all about
what's going on in the movies how that's
going to be different from what they're
doing with the characters on the TV show
the new Geoff Johns TV show I don't
really have to get into spoilers for the
comics thankfully some of you might not
be caught up on what's going on but
there's a couple key differences in the
rosters it's a little confusing it's
kind of a mess so I'll try to explain
the differences in what's going on what
Geoff Johns has been teasing for the
Titans TV show in what's different about
the DC EU version of the characters
double bonus - they're looking to beef
up Wonder Woman's presence across all
the big TV properties just because she's
such a big character now there's a
couple ways they can do that so I try to
talk about that relative to Titans at
the end of the video - there's a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video so there
are a couple of key differences between
DC EU Nightwing there you know confirmed
movies going to be happening whatever
might happen with any of the TV shows
the movies always take president he'll
be around early 20s I'll talk about
stories for that in a second I want to
address the Titans roster because
there's a lot of questions about which
version of Robin they're going to be
using because Geoff Johns was teasing
changeling or Beast Boy however you want
to think about it he's one of the few
people that they've confirmed so any of
the rosters they go with there are some
core Teen Titans characters but Geoff
Johns posted this picture here from his
run on Teen Titans that's volume 3 if
you want to read that that implies a few
roster changes from what's going on with
Titans in the comics right now so Teen
Titans and Titans are two completely
different teams one is a bunch of
teenagers one is a bunch of
20-somethings but Nightwing is a key
member of the Titans squad right now and
DC rebirth is just killing it so much
that I think they're going to try and
borrow a lot of the energy is not plot
lines with a few really classic deep
cuts for original Teen Titans stories
because the thing about Titans is they
make a lot of references to each other
about adventures they used to have when
Jeff Jones first came on the Teen Titans
book they had just killed Donna Troy but
right now in the Titans book she's alive
and well there have been a whole bunch
of changes so surprisingly the movie
universe is going to be way simpler for
them to figure out then
going to be for the TV show and that's
nothing to say of how it's going to be
connected to the air over which they
have not confirmed yet the current DC
rebirth roster right now is Nightwing
Donna Troy who doesn't really have a
Wonder Girl name but technically she's
Wonder Girl the ginger adult Wally West
tempest Arsenal omen in bumblebee what
they done in rebirth is they sort of
split the team so you have a lot of
classic Teen Titans characters like
Raven is a classic Teen Titans character
in the comics right now she's still very
young
so it's not going to be this complicated
on the TV show but when they were
originally developing the Teen Titans TV
show at the TNT network
it was Nightwing Starfire and Raven were
the only confirmed characters Geoff
Johns threw Beast Boy into the ring but
either way getting down to it is really
hard to have a TV character that's also
in the movies Amanda Waller
r.i.p I think they mostly got rid of on
arrow because the actress became a
series regular on another TV show I
don't think it was as much because of
what was going on in the movies but I do
think that they tried to downplay that a
little bit when the Suicide Squad movie
blew up and then when it didn't blow up
I think they backed off a little bit on
the TV show so they're like okay you can
do Suicide Squad stuff if you want the
best example of that is them teasing an
all-animal Suicide Squad on the flash
later in the season so if you haven't
seen that I don't want to give away
spoilers for that but let's just say all
the biggest CG animal characters on the
Suicide Squad flash TV show so even
though I've been talking a lot about
Titans of rebirth in the Nightwing
roster I still think that Dick Grayson
Nightwing rebirth is important for movie
DCE you Nightwing now by the time he
shows up they'll already had one Justice
League movie maybe even two depending on
how long it takes them to make this
Nightwing movie because it sounds like
Batgirl is moving along a little bit
faster just because Joss Whedon is
attached to it even though he's helping
out with Justice League I still feel
like he's a priority for the studio so
they're like okay write your scripts
find your Batgirl make your movie we
will do whatever you want us to do but
the nightly movie is a little bit harder
to nail they haven't found the actor yet
the director is the director of the Lego
Batman movie which was fantastic but is
obviously very different from what's
going on of the DC EU right now in
thankfully if you haven't been reading
it Nightwing
rebirth has been amazing there's a lot
of really good examples of why the
character is so much more fun than
Batman he talks about learning to put on
a show before he could barely walk
there's a sense of theatricality that's
just so much more fun
Batman is all about theatricality but
he's always so serious so it's fun to
have Nightwing around so that he can
poke fun at that the other really fun
thing about the Titans TV show is that
the comic books lend themselves to TV
shows a little bit better than they do
to the movies is a lot harder to jam a
really big comic book arc into a single
two two and a half hour movie than it is
to do during a season of television even
though there's a lot of crossover with
characters like you have Deathstroke in
the movies right now it's still being
played by Joe Manganiello they haven't
said anything about him being out so
assume that he is still in there
somewhere
until they say nope we're not doing
Deathstroke anymore he's just too big of
a get too big of a character too
attractive from a box-office standpoint
so you don't really need to worry too
much about the TV shows just because
whatever they do in the movies it's not
going to be a comic book story it'll be
based on a comic book story and they'll
definitely borrow characters but they
have access to all that Teen Titans
stuff even though they're calling it
Titans so that's the great thing is that
you have all this other stuff so if you
ever wondered why some of those classic
Young Justice characters like Cheshire
or Shiva never showed up in the air
overs it's because they were bookmarked
for the Titans TV show so even if they
opted to not connect the Titans TV show
with the air overs they just have much
more freedom in the comic book stories
they can do then the movies do is the
problem is that you walk into the DC EU
there's already all this story that
they've set up so anything that's
happened during Justice League all the
pre-existing history with Joker Harley
Quinn that Robin suit the implied dead
Robin although now that we know that
nightly exists we can confirm that that
was the Jason Todd version of the
character they've since come out and
said that there were a lot of questions
before Batman V Superman when it comes
to Titans Nightwing you're not saddled
with all that pre-existing story you can
just do it straight up from the comics I
mean there's a lot of similarities
Nightwing still went through under the
Red Hood he was a part of that arc but
you don't have a lot of the extra
baggage from what's going on with the
other movies in the DC EU so while you
might see somebody like Zac Efron or
Armie Hammer be Nightwing of the movie
universe do not be surprised if they
cast somebody that you've never seen
before but there's still so many big
questions with the roster like are they
going to do impulse are they gonna do
the Wally West kid flash if it's going
to be Titans is it really going to be
Titans or is it just going to be called
Titans with the Geoff Johns Teen Titans
roster which was vastly different from
what's going on with them right now so
thankfully we have comic-con coming up
that's when they tend to announce big
things like this they'll probably
release a partial roster but thank god
there's no writer strike he was getting
started with this before that all went
down last month so he'll have something
to show off by Comic Con but they
haven't really said anything about movie
night wing yet it would be really cool
if they did something like raptor from
DC rebirth if you haven't been reading
Nightwing rebirth it is badass the first
arc is called better than Batman and as
the name implies it's a really fun twist
on a Nightwing villain that's not quite
a villain it does a really good job of
showing you how he thinks differently
from Batman what separates him from the
Wayne family Batgirl is a huge part of
it I'm also hoping that she pops up in
the night we movie her movie will
probably drop first so hopefully they'll
be able to drop some references even if
they don't stick Nightwing in that but
let me know in the comments how do you
want them to differentiate movie
Nightwing from Titans Nightwing given
that they'll be about the same age the
reason why the Titans were created in
the first place why they stopped being
Teen Titans and they started calling
themselves just Titans is because they
passed the minimum age requirements to
join the Titans so they're like okay
you're way too old you need to move on
and go do other things so we can cycle
in a bunch of young kids and call them
two Teen Titans so that was kind of what
happened when Geoff Johns run took over
so they cycled the roster they brought
in the cassie sandsmark Wonder Girl I do
think that one of the biggest things
that they'll try to do on the Titans TV
show is find a place for a Wonder Girl
character because there is no Wonder
Woman presence on TV right now they
tease cheetah on the flash TV show
she's a Wonder Woman villain but that's
as close as we've gotten in the Wonder
Woman movie is blowing up so big right
now that they've already started talking
about a sequel so she's becoming a much
bigger presence in DC of Warner Brothers
so I think that Wonder Girl cassie
sandsmark or even Donna Troy are just
the easy slam-dunk for a TV version of
that world but you guys let me know they
end up doing some
Wonder Woman stuff somewhere in the
arrowverse or on the Titans TV show
probably Titans which version of the
character do you want them to do
assuming the gal gadot is never going to
go on a TV show that's the fun thing
about Nightwing is that he's not so big
but you just put him completely
off-limits the way you would Batman
Superman or Wonder Woman he's not one of
the Holy Trinity even though he's every
bit as cool as Batman the embargo is up
for a Wonder Woman Monday night so I'll
be posting my non-spoilery Wonder Woman
review really soon it'll probably be
Tuesday morning but there's a whole
bunch of other DC TV stuff going on
leave all your requests in the comments
I'll say congratulations to the latest
flash ring giveaway winner
Luke swag stuff please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details it was a
new round in this video I'll just
announce the winner the next time I post
a DC video you can click here to learn
all about the new scenes they're doing
for Justice League and you can click
here for brand new flash thank you so
much for watching
+ i-5 I'll see you guys tonight
you